a huge pot of love everybody was smiling
with each other greeting each other
it felt peaceful
[Music]
any about what really happened in the
Islamic story of of Jesus and his mother
hey it's like a straight line there's no
there's no deviation there's no
confusion and and that was like before I
even knew about Islam I kind of
discovered as a Christian you know pray
in the name of are sharing associating
partners with God was wrong when it's
when I found Islam innate explained to
me the Islamic belief of Jesus and his
mother and what had happened it made
more sense it felt more natural the
story was much more believable you guys
are probably wondering where we're at if
you haven't guessed already we're
actually at a place where Yusef you just
visited today right yes to say we're at
a graveyard and this is a place where in
actuality it's a future home for all of
us
you had a child years back six years six
months yes had passed away
what kind of coping mechanisms did you
find some people they turn away from God
altogether when something's project like
that happens
what kind of coping mechanisms and
answers that this law provides you that
you were able to deal with this sad and
tragic event that happen in your life
well that's a really good question um
you know at first I didn't know how to
take it I have experienced death you
know I mean personally and also friends
a lot of friends have died so I was kind
of an immune to it but I never lost
somebody that close like my son and a
brother had told me one day you know he
said brother don't worry about it it's
actually a huge blessing that you lost
your son I said well how can it be a
blessing you know he says well the
Prophet Mohammed peace be
you know said that the a lot when I was
dollar says that if Allah takes away a
child of a believer from the parents
that it's basically ticket to heaven and
that told me because that child will be
with asking patience you know give me a
lot of patience or I took I took it well
and it gave me something to look forward
to
brother Yousef how is your family it's
been a long time but have any of them
been receptive to the message do you
know that Islam simply means submission
of your will to gods well that's what it
means
people like wow I didn't know that most
of his one who has submitted to the will
of God he your but equal by ethnicity
rightness so he didn't change his DNA
he's still Hispanic but he's Muslim and
this is something that is growing
rapidly it's all over the world but upon
Allah within the span of community have
many of your family others have they
been receptive have some of them
accepted also this way of life can you
share with us your experiences with your
with your family and friends definitely
my parents it took them a while to get
used to the fact that I was no longer a
Christian my father he's never been very
religious so he just kept his mouth shut
about situation I guess we really know
him to say my mother gave me he'll for
years she's always been very into the
church and 20 years later now you know
we could sit down and and get along
alhamdulillah all praise is due to Allah
my sister has become a Muslim she's been
Muslim around I want to say seven or
eight years now and masha'Allah you know
I've seen her I've seen her make a
complete about-face I mean
I've lost for words I can't even explain
like the beauty that Islam is brought
into her life and you know she's my
little sister and believe it or not I
actually look up to my little sister
hamdulillah brother Yusuf from your
experience some people 20 years a long
time for people who are struggling now
you weber you were able to come overcome
a lot of odds with your family and we
can imagine some of the other struggles
some people just drop out it's like kind
of just like you you might have picked
the best university it's many people
fall back people and some people just
you know it's family enough it's a test
is its breath do you have for those out
there who are struggling they're also
you know it's long but they might be
hitting some of the struggles that you
went through what advice do you give
them
one thing that I'm not that I've learned
as a Muslim in my days you know I I find
that the best of us the best amongst us
are the ones that the Devil attacks the
most he fears certain people in my
opinion you know in a way it's almost
like he knows who who's here that can
lead many people closer to God so attack
you from every angle that you could
possibly think of patience it's an
absolute key to to everything in this
life in my opinion no matter what you're
going through a law says he loves those
who are the most patient and you know I
haven't always been patient admit I'm
still learning to become more and more
efficient as I go every day but focus on
not so much on what's going on around
you but learn to find yourself
unfortunately our days were so
distracted by you know money cars
clothes entertainments what you know
problems bills it's all set up to take
away from who we are taking
as I the advice I think that is really
important is focus really hard on
getting to know who you are as an
individual and be patient and try your
best to implement
[Music]
Blom it into your life just keep it
moving everything is already written so
there's really nothing you could give it
your best you know one day like Eddie
was saying one day we're all gonna we're
all gonna face the music and phase of
death in the meantime do the best that
you could do don't beat yourself up and
be appreciated for what you have because
once it's over you can't go back many
people when you bring up this reality of
death it's a scary scary reality but
it's a reality that's supposed to have
us grounded you know when you look here
all these people had ambitious they had
dreams you know and you can see that
they had a birth date and end date a
start date and an end date and we have
been given we know our birth date but
our death date we don't know when it's
coming
but Islam that's the beautiful thing
that it helps us to prepare for that
moment when death I'm scary
but the feeling of hope comes into
something better awaits
a full potential we live morally upright
lives and we worship one God the Creator
not the creation we do good deeds like
fall short right but he's the loving the
most kind the most merciful we always
turn back to our Creator and we
appreciate these of the reality of death
and that's one of the things that really
got me in check was this reality
thinking about that
and now numb to it for many people they
kind of just joke it off or they like I
don't want to entertain the topic how it
is is your life disrespected like a bath
or you like today what would go to your
mind earlier what was going through your
mind when you were visiting the grave
earlier today it's long past death
and life into until you perspective for
me and I feel that as LOM is preparing
me you know this is temporary this is
the life of this woman is temporary you
know in the carotids luster the life is
raw temporary it's an illusion it does
it's not to hold on to it you know to
live this life as if you're a traveller
as you're just passing brutal as lamas
giving me fort before I suffer death Oh
what am I gonna do where am I gonna go
now I am patiently awaiting it with a
smile on my face in order to I'm looking
forward to be my lord one day that's
beautiful that that sound you have that
perspective when you had that
perspective balance
helps us stick hey let me take our part
in this world we don't abandon this
we're all together but like you said
taking the advice from the last final
messenger sentiment and kind of problem
aha may peace and blessings be upon and
who said be in this life as if you are
travelling so we know that this abode
this life is transitory but the ultimate
home that's forever ever is in the next
life
so we strive to meet our Creator
definitely we work in this life to do
the good deeds to do everything living
life how he wants us to live so when we
leave we're in a good standing and
please our Lord before we meet our Lord
before we meet our Creator so we can
enter into the genuine to the paradise
and avoid the health definitely I want
to thank you Yousef for being with me
here the audience on the D show so thank
you guys for tuning in for another
episode of the Dean show make sure to
subscribe hit the notification bell if
you haven't already so we can continue
to deliver these shows to you with some
of the amazing guests amazing stories
and just remember that advice that was
given to us by our Creator then not to
get attached it's over and over it
stated in the verbatim Word of God the
Quran talking about this life being a
transitory abode that the real home is
the home in the hereafter so I have this
hand this world in your hand but not in
your heart so when it's time to
disattach you'll be able to say bye-bye
but if you fall in love so deeply with
this transitory world you take what you
need to take from it you work you
provide you have an honest
you work and have honest day's living
and you do all the things and succeed in
your business and your trade and
everything else that you do but the
point is not to just fixate yourself
with this what you see here and not
invest in the permanent home in the next
life that's not a balance so make sure
that we take from that what Allah is
telling us warning over and over in the
crowd and show how they can help us
deliver more fruitful and balanced life
and be looking forward and motivated to
what's waiting for us
in Jenna paradise in the next thank you
guys for tuning in
hope you got the Bennett from from
Yousef story you will see you next time
until then peace be with you i said i'll
make her walk out